herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich habe heute mal wieder
was eingekauft die haben
unterschiedlichste brotaufstriche die
wir zum aller ersten mal im supermarkt
entdeckt haben wir waren in so einem
ganz neuen edeka also keine ahnung
vielleicht gibts das bei euch auch schon
aber ich hab das zum ersten mal gesehen
dachte mir warum beziehungsweise
angedachte sich auf jeden fall dass ich
mir das ist definitiv ein video wert wir
vergleichen nämlich heute brotaufstrich
also süßigkeiten als brotaufstrich was
das original das sie sind alle möglichen
brotaufstriche wir haben tricks wir
haben momentan ist sie am mount wayne
und wir testen einfach mal wie gut das
original getroffen wurde und anderen
glaube ich hunger darüber hüllt schon
brot vorbereitet einmal kurz klatschen
firma ab
[Applaus]
ich würde sagen tut mir alles zur seite
außerdem muss weil die kann man
schlechte seite und und wir testen den
spaß meine ruhe eröffnen wir mal die
packungen das hier ist gm und ems creme
da sind oben so knusper perlen drauf
messer und streichelt aber auch ein brot
drauf bevor ich den brotaufstrich teste
nehme ich erst mal ein paar normale
modems die schmecken überraschend lecker
ich esse eigentlich nie war jana ist die
süßigkeiten beauftragte bei uns in der
wohnung in die kaufen immer süßigkeiten
und die machen wir die originale modems
jetzt hätte ich den brotaufstrich weiß
nicht ob das getoppt werden kann oder ob
das dem gerecht werden kann aber
probiert habe mich kriegen sie diesen
kranken meister von den e mails von
dieser schade außen und der einen kranz
100 nein hätte diese schale ist voll
fast 100 prozent also der geschmack ist
bei den m a teams ein bisschen
dahingeschmolzen kosten nicht okay
die nächste möglichkeit dem brot
auftritt der kranz ist da oder das ist
wirklich hätte also diese perlen da oben
drauf so richtig heftig aber bei der
probe in embsen brotjob vorläufig du
herkommst und bequem unter leute man
darf nicht abhängig macht trotzdem stark
nein so schmeckt einfach irgendwie
vollen teller wo wir nicht nach aber
auch nicht nach eminems lecker ist es
auf jeden fall sehr der kran ist gut
warum eigentlich schon sehr gelungen
dafür dass es halt ein ganz anderes
medium ist das ist ja jetzt was medium
brotaufstrichen ich gebe dem ganz
von zehn möglichen sieben punkte so
leute perspektive gewechselt damit wir
ein bisschen besser beleuchtet sind
berichtet sind wir haben schon die
nächste sache hier vor uns stehen es
handelt sich um nichts geringeres als
tricks dann habe ich das nächste mal
tricks gegessen ich habe fünf minuten
ja ja jetzt lange her wer trickst ist
nicht so dass ich mir irgendwie diesen
keks oder so aber diese creme ist so
lecker deshalb leute open web so leute
hier ist der tricks brotaufstrich sieht
von oben ganz normal aus hat mit dem ovi
so etwas besonderes drin aber wenn
jemand reinkommt das sind so kleine
hügel hier drin vielleicht sind da diese
ist wie teile drin die auch in tricks
drin sind diese keks teile das wäre
natürlich krass glaube wir probieren
schnell weil sonst kommt er her gar
nicht klar
hmm also leute testen wir als nächstes
den tracks brotaufstrich geh einfach
einmal tief rein und da sind solche
grundstücke drin und das heftige ist
wenn man dann riecht es riecht so geil
nach karamell übel oder bor ich das
lecker als bereit dass anschlussinhaber
dieses kranjec innen drin wird dem
tricks boden leider nicht gerecht man
aber egal wenn es nicht endlich und das
halt so übel tätig aber ich würde dieser
creme nur sechs geben so leute also das
sieht ja wohl schon mal geil aus ich bin
fan von baur ist aber eigentlich fast
nie also wir öffnen und wir probieren
all diese schokoriegel erinnern nicht
extrem an die zeit bei ihr eingezogen
sind wir sind gerade bei unserer familie
und da habe ich mich dann immer
angezogen sind in mein zimmer gelegt und
hab irgendwie schokoriegel bekommen hat
dann so ein achter pack schokoriegel
essen und dabei gewesen
harry-potter-star die freude haben
so sieht das ganze aus leute ich weiß
wir bisher kennen könnte sind glaube ich
hier so kleine stückchen drin
wahrscheinlich diesmal kokosraspeln und
wir testen den spaß jetzt einfach mal
aus wie schwer das schmeckt ja da ist
fehlt ja komplett die schokolade
eigentlich die außen rum es bei einer
anlage ist schokolade drin hier ist
einfach nur geistig willst du dich weiße
schokolade ausdrücklich wo ist es viel
viel cremiger als die anderen
das richtig geil so was kennt man auch
noch die andere hatten ja so
ähnlichkeiten mit nutella oder martina
drucker oder sonstwas dass leute das ist
geil was hat potenzial das ist richtig
das brot oder der des wortes einfach
lecker leute und ist das legal was ich
jetzt mache
[Gelächter]
also ich würde bounty das war definitiv
das beste bisher 8,5 ausziehen ausziehen
weil ich weiß ja noch nicht ob die noch
eine maß krämer finden und riet ihnen
schmeckt bei manchen okay also ich gebe
ab 14 jahren noch sehen das ist schon
sehr gut wenn ihr was austesten wollte
dann würde ich das empfehle ich auch so
leute jetzt kommen wir zu der sache auf
die ich persönlich am längsten gewartet
habe einfach weiß so ultra cool aussieht
milky way
wer hat das gedacht dass menschen aus
leute mikey way creme und das coolste
daran ist dass es zwei farbig ist meine
vision ist dass es zwei cremes sind die
komplett unterschiedlich schmecken
machen wir einmal mit einer zunge
sondern höchster weil es war noch jemand
anderes essen soll ich habe kein problem
damit ist die frage wie testen wie es am
besten erst müssen wir natürlich unseren
erinnerungen auffrischen
lange lange nicht gegessen du auch nicht
wir testen den spaß einfach frei 2 1 die
werben damit irgendwie ist das total
leicht sei oder aber das ist der einzige
schokoriegel unser papa ist oder stimmt
er hat immer mit über gegessen
ich hätte auch mal mittels passwort
irgendwo möchte mick nähten
verschiedene auf twitter und dafür die
sachen probieren wir einfach mal die
creme ich geht mitten rein und probieren
das beste von beiden welt liegt wieder
absolut noch gar nichts oder noch gar
nicht nach feiern ist eigentlich ehrlich
sagen ich esse gar nicht so gerne so ein
toller song brotaufstrich ich esse immer
nur süßigkeiten ohne abstriche dass du
so gern süß kassen das glaube ich jeder
und habe ich sagen dass mir das mal
schmeckt mir nicht ich bin eigentlich
gut so ist es jetzt einmal nur das helle
das voll der fake wahlweise warum das
links ist einfach weißer schokolade und
das recht zu sein also
vollmilchschokolade es geht doch auch so
hasst von wenn man das separat ist dann
hat das hat gar nichts mit geld zu tun
und zu zweit auch nicht möglich alles
ein bisschen am ziel vorbei auf jeden
fall ich finde aber allgemein ist das
nicht schlecht also schmeckt ganz gut
jetzt die herzlich geschmeckt ich würde
dem vielleicht sieben konzern geben oder
nein sagen 89 10 8 von 10 wirklich
gelebt du projektion nicht mehr kennt
das wenn den kuchen backt da habt ihr
diese puppen klausur ist da noch so was
von ihm übrig ich denke sowohl
geschlossen schokolade nimmt immer
schmeckt nicht nur schokolade nur noch
fett so leute haben alles getestet ich
würde sagen auf dem letzten platz
befindet sich bei mir
patrick's brotaufstrich zu mir ich
glaube wir sind uns einig dass auf dem
dritten platz
[Musik]
ich hatte auf den dritten platz landet
der m&m brotaufstrich weil der waschen
eis also ich waren den gut mit diesem
und platz 1 sind wir uns einige bauern
die bei mir platz zwei das war der test
generell können die mit den regeln mit
halten bzw mit den süßigkeiten schwierig
würde ich saß bitte sagt er nein weil
die wege doch irgendwie noch mal anders
schmecken man kann es eigentlich nicht
so wirklich vergleichen also dass wir
jetzt einen kokon aufstrich oder so das
ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach gut fürs
marketing wenn man es dann baut hindern
kann aber die regel sind geil ich würde
auch sagen die süßigkeiten an sich sind
geiler ist es leider nichts als würdest
du dein brot zum riesigen bounty
verwandeln wenn es hier darauf mir ist
aber eine nette abwechslung zu nutella
deshalb von mir einen daumen hintersten
video wieder servus